somebody asked a question about iran you
guys heard about iran and uranus
i want to get pat's opinion on this so
please let's talk about enriching
uranium to yeah 20
purity we got uh five more minutes on
this year tehran returns to pre-nuclear
deal levels of uranium enrichment the
nuclear activity
which returns iran to an enrichment
level at its uh at last
reached before entering the
international core dials up pressure on
washington across a red line
set by european countries that remained
committed
to the agreement after the trump
administration withdrew from it in 2018
the move threatens to complicate
president-elect joe biden's plan to
rejoin the deal that placed limits on
tehran's nuclear program but which
floundered
after the u.s left it and reimposed
crippling economic sanctions on tehran
mr biden has said the u.s would join
rejoin the deal as long as iran complies
with the terms the enrichment activity
also raises tensions in the middle east
which
when the region is already on edge
during the warning
days of trump administration
iran nuclear iranian forces sees a south
korea flagship on monday according to a
semi-official iranian news agency
heightening tensions with the u.s
ally forces brought boarded the vessel
because it was
creating unspecified pollution the
persian gulf the agency said the vessel
owner dm shipping of busan south korea
didn't respond to calls what do you
think what's going on right now with the
soil i i want to get your opinion more
than
more than tom and i's this is something
i think right in your wheelhouse i know
a couple
episodes ago you kind of enlightened us
on the
what the pros and cons are where a lot
of cons on the iran
pay for play all right stop do this just
basic iran historically
uh uh uh anybody in iran
who okay so politically think about it
this way i showed a chart which i can't
do it here but i'll just show it to you
this way okay
if there is a a republican president
okay or democratic president the
democratic president republican leader
you have a democratic president there
republican leader so
if if the leader is republican in iran
okay they fear dems
okay so the shah republican right
conservative
he fears a carter okay
if the the country is hardcore
right now where it's hezbollah's you
know don't bother don't do any of that
stuff and they're not pro-america
they're not westerners they don't
believe in
the freedom of speech type of deal where
the shah wanted to give all these
freedoms to people
you don't need to put on uh you know
your uh uh
job you don't have to do all this stuff
you're free woman can do this woman
don't have to
marry at 13. you want to increase the
age you have more voice you have to do
this
okay the left kind of didn't like that
and then on the other side if it's
hardcore hardcore controls
they don't like republicans because
republicans want to give you more
freedom
they want people to have freedom of
speech they want people to have freedoms
but when it's hardcore hardcore like
this
they kind of like democrats because they
don't fear democrats
because democrats just want to say
listen it's okay let's just make it work
it's not a big deal what can we give you
for you not to be
you know we'll make you happy so biden
they're so
happy about president-elect joe biden
iran the current regime of iran is so
happy
about biden and when biden comes back
into power unless it comes
comes into power when this thing takes
place whatever the chances are
everybody's talking about thirty percent
five percent
ninety nine point nine percent zero
percent when this thing happens and
biden's there
you know the deal is going to come up
there's no question about it
the deal is going to come up there's no
question about it they're going to go
out there to
rebuild and even more than that
do you really think whether they have
the money or not do you think they're
gonna listen to anybody my biggest thing
has always been accountability how do
you hold those guys accountable they
don't they're not gonna
they don't sit there and say we're not
gonna do what you tell us to do we're
gonna do whatever we wanna do that's
their mentality you don't tell us what
to do
they'll take your money gladly and turn
around and say death upon america
they don't look at america as a partner
they look at america in a different way
but in this situation here this is their
way of saying we're already going back
into it
and if you don't give us the money
here's what we're going to do so it's a
way of saying hey budden prepare
yourself because you're about to have
a hostage situation exactly what it is
so um
this 20 purity and i'm no nuclear
scientist you know breaking news here
what does that mean what happens when it
gets to 30 50
percent wha what like i think we can
always we don't know
nuclear yeah scientists you know i i
decided to go into insurance after
nuclear plants that we had all over
bring us back to your roots pat when you
were iranian
here's the percentage you have to worry
about if iran gets a nuclear
weapon there's a 100 chance they
probably use it that's why you have to
do whatever you can to make sure they
don't get it but even if they do use it
does that not automatically mean that
they are wiped off the planet because
israel will use it on them the united
states will use it on them saudi arabia
will you know whatever they'll do so
it's the same reason north korea is not
using it right like north korea you
send a missile you you no longer exist
so doesn't that where does that factor
into the hostage situation and
they they do what they want to do hey do
you think do you think biden's going to
get rid of all the sanctions on iran
because they
they work when you put sanctions on iran
and you cut their economy off
you know it works especially when you
get the whole world to persuasion i
think there's a
70 chance he does 30 chance that he does
not
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you